on this special episode of game life I
get rid of here and talk to you about
two of the rarest games on the Gameboy
now as many of you may already know I am
an inveterate collector of old video
games so what I thought I would do with
you guys today is maybe show you a
couple of new games that I have give you
a few tips on collecting and yeah maybe
I'll brag a little bit about some of the
best deals that I have ever gotten so
we're gonna take a look at two games
today for the Game Boy family of systems
so first I would like to talk about
ninja five-o now as you might gather
from the title yes this is a Game Boy
Advance game about a ninja who's also a
cop it's by Konami it's actually a great
game and that's why it's so desired
people really want to play it because
it's really one of the best action games
on the Game Boy Advance now if you just
have the ninja five-o cartridge you are
probably gonna pay a hundred and fifty
dollars that is how desired this game is
if you've got the box and instructions
as I do here we're talking three hundred
dollars or or more people tended not to
keep the boxes and the manuals for their
old games and that really went double
for Game Boy games because people would
throw the box out and take the game with
them in the car so to have the Box in
manual for games like this becomes
really important no how much did I pay
wasn't three hundred and it even wasn't
one hundred and fifty I actually found
this in a secondhand store in Boston for
twelve bucks a couple of years ago and
boy did my eyes bug out of my head when
I did now let's take a look at one more
game this is kid Dracula and it is for
the black-and-white Game Boy as you
might imagine you play a little tiny
version of Dracula running around a
castle and setting fire to bats or
whatever it is that a child Dracula
would do this as you might notice is
also by Konami and because it stars
Dracula you might guess correctly that
it's a spin-off of the very popular
Castlevania series so if you don't have
kids
Dracula on the Gameboy your collection
of Castlevania games is not complete kid
Dracula was done with a really low print
run and again people really want to play
this game which means that the cartridge
itself is gonna set you back about 50
bucks here's the kicker the the box and
the manual in good condition like this
is worth 400 dollars or so where did I
get this you ask I actually found this
in a video game store in Manhattan that
is known for having really high prices
on everything but here's the trick guys
when you go into a high-priced video
game store don't immediately get bummed
out they have to be right every single
time they price something but you only
have to get lucky once and look up the
prices on everything then you might
catch a deal like I did with kid Dracula
I paid $50 but it's really worth about
eight times that and those are two of
the coolest video game items out of my
collection now what I want to hear from
you guys is about the best deals that
you've ever gotten so make a video
response to this drop it in the comments
show me some of the best deals you've
ever gotten on old video games and hey
if you've got a video game where you
really don't know if it's worth anything
what it's worth make a video response
show it off and ask and if I can I'll
get in there in the comments and let you
know what I think it would go for